[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This next panel is
going to be talking
about the role of the ocean in
climates, as a climate driver,
and how it's
affected by climates.
Just on a personal
note, after my trip
to the Marshall Islands,
I became obsessed
with sea surface temperatures.
So once a week, I would
check the NOAA Sea Surface
Temperature Anomaly
Plot and post it
onto Facebook, which earned
a lot of funny comments
from my friends.
But to introduce the
topic and to moderate,
we have Amala Mahadevan,
who was a Radcliffe
Fellow for a number of years.
She's a senior scientist at
the Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institute.
And she studies phytoplankton,
but also an interesting twist.
Phytoplankton and the
hydrodynamics of the ocean.
How upwellings and
gyres and vortices
can affect different organisms.
So it's an interesting
combination
of fluid dynamics and biology.
So Amala.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you, John.
So in today's panel, we're
very excited here to tell you
a little bit about how the
oceans shape our climate.
And since the early
history of the Earth,
I would say the oceans
really have defined
the climate on this Earth.
We have seen that the inception
of life, the evolution of life
happened on the ocean.
But also, the oceans regulate
the atmospheric carbon dioxide
and oxygen.
And the oceans contain,
for that matter,
a very large percentage
of the Earth's water,
97% of the Earth's
water is in the oceans.
Just about 0.001% of the
water is in the atmosphere,
just to give you an idea.
The oceans contain 98%
of the carbon dioxide,
in dissolved form, of course.
So when we say that
atmospheric carbon dioxide is
going up or going down,
you have to realize
that there's a lot in
the oceans and the oceans
have, in the past, regulated
the atmospheric carbon dioxide
very well.
Whether they can do
that in the future
is something that
we are still asking.
And the oceans-- you know,
if you think about heat,
where is all the heat, most
of the heat, 90% of the heat,
is in the oceans.
So in many ways, the
oceans define the climate.
The circulation of the
oceans defines the climate.
And about half the primary
production on the Earth
takes place in the oceans.
And we see that the
oceans are constantly
in a state of motion.
These ocean currents,
they transport heat
across the oceans.
They transport salt.
And in the very
fundamental way, the oceans
are different from
the atmosphere.
One is that they have
enormous heat capacity.
But the atmosphere
is heated from below.
And so the energy of the sun
is what drives the atmosphere.
Whereas the oceans, when
you heat them by the sun,
in fact, it's
stratifies the oceans,
or it creates a
density contrast,
because warmer
water doesn't sink.
So in fact, you
see that the winds
are what drive the
ocean to a large extent.
And mixing or
overturning the oceans
is, in fact, very
difficult, because the sun
warms the oceans.
So in a nutshell, that
tells you that it's
difficult to communicate
changes through the oceans.
But the oceans really
support a large part
of our primary production
on this planet.
And so about half that
primary production
takes place in the oceans.
And that organic
matter, as we have
seen in some of the previous
talks, it sinks very gradually.
Some of it get sequestered,
that carbon to the oceans.
So the big perturbation
that we've made,
that humankind has
made, is that we
have taken out that
organic carbon that's
fossilized for millions
and millions of years.
We have very abruptly brought
it out into the atmosphere.
And we have created
huge changes.
And I have to say that
the ocean has buffered,
is buffering, a
lot of that change
that we might see because
of those abrupt changes.
A third of the CO2 that we
put out in the atmosphere
has gone into the oceans.
And when we talk
about global warming,
and if you were to ask,
where is all that heat that
has to do with
global warming, why
is it that we don't
feel very warm today,
it's because 90% of that
heat is in the oceans.
So I'm really excited today
to have this panel here.
We have here three
oceanographers
whom I really admire,
whose work I really admire.
Maureen Raymo from the
Lamont-Doherty Earth
Observatory at Columbia.
And she has worked on the
past climate of the Earth.
And her work has
shown how important it
is to think about past climates,
and how past climates help
us understand the changes that
we're going to go through now,
or we're going
through at present.
That's because we have a very
short observational window
in these last few decades.
And so understanding past
climate is really important.
And then we have
Rebecca Woodgate,
who is an arctic oceanographer.
And she's done a lot of
observations in the Arctic.
And she's really pushed
our understanding
of how sea ice and
the oceans interact.
And the big changes that
are occurring in the Arctic,
it's one of the most vulnerable
regions in the oceans because
of the sea ice and the
interaction with the oceans.
And then we have
Lynne Talley, who
has been instrumental in
understanding the large scale
distribution of
temperature, salt,
and the global
circulation of the oceans.
How these things get conveyed
and transported across
the oceans, what
are the changes?
And she's been
instrumental in some
of the very big ocean
observing programs
that have global and
international programs.
And her understanding
of the global oceans
through those
programs has really
changed a lot of
our understanding
as oceanographers.
So it gives me enormous pleasure
to have these three people here
today.
I don't want you to go away
thinking that oceanographers
are necessarily women, but some
of the best oceanographers are.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
- Well, thank you, Amala.
And thank you for
inviting me to speak here.
I'm very happy to be here.
So let me just
get right into it.
Hopefully, you've had
time to get the joke.
I should also say that
video of the ocean swirling
is one of my favorite
videos in the whole world.
It's called perpetual
ocean if you
want to pull it up and
watch the whole world.
OK.
So I've spent most of my career
studying past climate change.
And most of the last five to 10
years studying sea level as it
relates to the past history
of the polar ice sheets.
And today, there's two
major polar ice sheets.
There's the one in Greenland,
which if you, hypothetically,
could melt it all and
spread it in a single layer
over the ocean, sea
level would rise
by about six meters or 20 feet.
And then in the
South Pole, there's
the West Antarctic
ice sheet over here,
which again, is about the
same size as the Greenland ice
sheet.
And then the much larger
East Antarctic ice sheet,
which you have to go
back 40 million years
to find a time when that
whole ice sheet had melted.
And at that time, sea level
was about 180 feet higher
than today.
So the question
I'll just pose here
is, how sensitive
are these ice sheets
to a modest global warming?
And by modest, I mean,
let's say one degree
Celsius warmer than today.
I actually know a little
bit about a time period
that is widely
agreed to have been
two to three degrees
warmer than pre-industrial,
which would be one to two
degrees warmer than today.
And at that time, geochemists,
using various methods,
have reconstructed
atmospheric CO2.
It is about 400 PPM,
which I know at least some
of the people in the room I
recognize know that's exactly
what it is today.
It's about 401 this week, PPM.
It should be 280 PPM, but
we'll come back to that.
And what I'm showing
here is a site
on the north coast
of Ellesmere Island,
and an artist's
reconstruction based
on the fossils, and
plants, and animals,
and pollen that have been
taken out of that dig
show a reconstruction
of what the north
coast of Greenland
and Canada looked
like three million years ago.
The Greenland ice
sheet did not exist.
OK.
So climate is
changing all the time.
Even more recently, there's been
a profound change in climate.
This is 21,000 years
ago, very recently.
And obviously, the
Greenland ice sheet
has jumped the Davis Strait and
has expanded dramatically down
over North America
and Fennoscandia.
I don't know if this is a big
Game of Thrones crowd in here,
but if the people that like
it will appreciate this quote.
So that is the height
of the ice sheet
over Boston at the peak
of the last ice age.
OK.
So that was just a blink
of time ago, obviously.
So why do these changes happen?
The climate system is
infinitely complicated.
And there's no
scientist on our planet
that can be an expert in every
part of the climate system.
But at the same time,
it's somewhat very simple.
And you can go to the radiation
chapter in a freshman physics
book and see a very
simple equation
to calculate the effect of
temperature of the Earth.
We don't need that, but
all you need to know
is it's very simple.
And the surface
temperature of the Earth
just adds one more
variable, which
is the concentration
of greenhouse gases.
And so I like to
think about it when
I talk to general
audiences, just say, look,
the Earth's climate,
the temperature
of the Earth-- we're
a ball of rock.
We get heated by this star
that's a distance away-- which
I don't know-- one light year?
I don't know.
And there's three
variables that control
the Earth's temperature.
How close we are to
the sun-- and that
actually varies
subtly through time
because our orbit isn't
perfectly circular,
and other large planets
perturb our orbit,
like Jupiter and
Saturn, on time scales
of tens to hundreds of thousands
of years in very predictable
ways that can be calculated.
And sometimes, over
billions of years,
the solar output of
the sun can change.
But on human time scales,
it's essentially constant,
which is why we call
it solar constant.
So that's one big knob
you can change that can
control Earth's temperature.
The other is the Earth's
albedo or reflectivity.
If you expand the snow and ice
coverage at high latitudes,
you make the Earth
more reflective.
And so more of the
solar radiation
is just lost to space.
It's reflected to space.
It's not available for heating.
I'm sure we'll hear a lot more
about that in the Arctic talk.
And then, finally, we have this
thing called greenhouse gases.
And so we have all this
heat coming in from the sun.
It's warming the
Earth's surface.
The Earth's surface is
cooler than the sun,
so it re-radiates outward
at longer wavelengths.
And it just happens to interfere
with the molecular structure
of certain gases,
especially CO2, which
can prevent it from escaping.
And then re-radiates
it back to the surface.
So just like throwing more
blankets on on a cold winter
night.
So these are the three knobs.
And everything I know about
every climate change that
has happened in
the past-- and this
I will show you-- can
be explained by just
changing these three variables.
And I'm going to
show you a model.
This is the climate model with
an ice sheet embedded in it.
And it's the last 400,000 years.
This is a sea level scale.
And this is what the climate
for the last 400 years
has looked like, just
the only variables
being our variable
orbit around the sun,
changes in the
Earth's precession
and tilt of the Earth's
axis, and the CO2
changes that we know
occurred from ice cores.
And it actually-- this
is a model result,
but it looks remarkably like
what we know climate did.
Want to see that again?
- Yeah.
- I could watch it all day.
This is a paper we published in
Nature by Ayako Abe-Ouchi, who
is actually the only
female scientist I've ever
met in my field from Japan.
So one of the things
you may notice
is that ice sheets grow
much slower than they
melt. It's very easy to
melt an ice sheet quickly.
And the reason is
because, as you see,
as it starts to retreat,
the ice sheet has
depressed the land under it.
And so the ocean can
flow in very quickly
and destroy that ice sheet from
below as well as from above.
So ice sheets can
melt very quickly
because they can become
unstable and warm ocean
can flow under them.
How quickly?
This is data-- well,
this is the results
of a study of Tahiti
in the Western Pacific.
And what the scientists
did was they went offshore
and they drilled down.
And they can, with very
precise dating and drilling,
determine the depth below
sea level of the coral
as it tracked the sea level rise
at the end of the last ice age.
So as the ice sheets are melting
quickly, the seas are rising,
the coral is keeping up.
It can do that.
And they were able to
determine that as the last ice
sheet deglaciated,
sea level was rising
at rates of 40 millimeters per
year, or 12 feet per century.
So keep that number in your
mind as we move forward here.
Right now, sea level's
rising to three millimeters
per century-- sorry, per year.
Did I say century?
I meant year.
Three millimeters per year.
But how high was sea
level during some
of these little periods in the
past that were just slightly
warmer than today?
This is a question that's
very easy to answer
and also very
difficult to answer.
It's very easy
because the evidence
for higher sea levels during the
recent past is all around you.
This is me standing with my
postdoc, Nick [? O'Leary ?].
This is the modern Ningaloo reef
system in Northwest Australia.
We are standing on a
stranded fossilized reef that
is probably about 400,000 years
old from a time period that
was slightly warmer than today.
This is a reef.
This is the fossilized coral.
This is my student Mike
Sandstrom from the Cape ranges
of Western Australia.
That's from the last
interglacial warm period,
125,000 years ago.
It's a few meters above
present day sea level.
This is from a three
million year old deposit
in Pliocene, the Pliocene
warm period in Africa.
No coral, but we have fossil
oysters with fossil barnacles
still on the fossil oysters.
I mean, ooh, you're
at sea level.
But why is it difficult?
We see this evidence for
high sea levels everywhere.
The major reason
it's difficult is
because the ocean--
unfortunately, the ocean basin
is not like this tub.
And you can't just look at
these as like bathtub rings
from the past.
The continents, the crust of
the sea floor, and the land,
they're constantly in motion.
They're being loaded and
unloaded by ice sheets,
by water.
It's constantly moving.
So it's quite a
challenging problem.
And there's a fantastic
group here at Harvard
led by Jerry Mitrovica
that's been working on this.
And many clever
scientists around the room
have made huge progress in
unraveling these challenges
over the last five to 10 years.
So I'll jump right to
a summary slide, which
is in a paper we published
in Science last year.
And so here's-- and this is
kind of a complicated slide,
but it's really cool too.
So here's a CO2 scale.
There's pre-industrial CO2.
Here's present day CO2.
And here's a sea level scale.
And here's today's ice volume.
One degree warmer than
pre-industrial right now.
Here's 125,000 years ago.
The CO2 was the same
during that warm period,
but we were just so
slightly closer to the sun,
it was warmer.
It was about one degree warmer.
A smidge because of the
precession of the Earth varied.
And all these different
studies as to-- the estimate
of all these
different studies is
that sea level is six to nine
meters higher than today.
OK?
And this is a window of time
that's 10,000 years long.
400,000 years ago, it
was a little bit warmer,
six to 13 meters best estimate.
And then in the
Pliocene, it's been
so long, the continents
have moved so much,
we have a very hard time.
Huge error bars.
We don't really know.
But two to three degrees warmer,
higher CO2, 400, same as today.
And I wish I could tell you
more exactly what sea level was
at that time.
I can't.
OK.
So you know, this is
6 meters, 20 feet.
Let's take it back to just
four feet, which is completely
within the realm of
what could happen
by the end of this century.
I'm perfectly comfortable
with this as a prediction.
And I'm sure there are
others that are as well.
So four feet above present.
Five million people live
within four feet of sea level
in the US today.
It's a huge amount in
Florida, obviously.
And in terms of our national
infrastructure, energy
facilities, ports,
Naval bases, there's
a huge amount of real estate
that is in this zone of risk.
Obviously, sea level
rise is not just
a problem of the United States.
It's a global problem.
And we may be hearing more about
the Marshall Islands later too.
Does anyone recognize
this capital city?
It's Mali.
It's the capital
of the Maldives.
And so you have
over 300,000 people
living on an island that's
a meter and a half above sea
level.
And this is just one of
like thousands and thousands
of inhabited islands
around the world.
And when you hear the
expression climate refugees,
this is what-- these
are people just like us
that you're hearing about.
OK?
So I'm going to basically leave
two more possibly depressing
thoughts about sea level rise.
And that is, first of all,
I think a lot of people
have this vague idea they'll
be able to deal with it,
like keep it back.
I don't believe that's
very realistic, just based
on my observations of
various places I love.
And the other thing that's
really important, I think,
for people to come to grips
with and tell themselves
is that sea level rise is
irreversible on the time
scale of centuries.
You could probably cool
the Earth's atmosphere
easier than you can
regrow an ice sheet.
So every year, the
increment of water
that's going in from the
melting of polar ice sheets
and the thermal expansion
of sea water, that's
an increment of sea
level rise that there,
and that we're going to have
to deal with for centuries
to come.
So to wrap that up,
what I know for sure,
climate is changing
naturally all the time.
Small variations,
very small variations
in incoming solar radiation,
albedo, reflectivity,
and greenhouse
gas concentrations
can lead to large and
sometimes rapid changes.
The activities of
seven billion people
are capable of causing
effects of this magnitude.
And here is the CO2,
carbon dioxide, record
of the last 10,000 years.
The Holocene, the
warm window of time
within which human culture,
agriculture flourished.
It was about 270
parts per million.
A subtle rise starts
about 5,000 years ago.
Many scientists believe this
is due to early agricultural
and deforestation.
And then here, this
interval right here,
blown up right here, here's
the 18th century, the beginning
of the Industrial Revolution.
And this rise is
the addition of CO2
to the atmosphere from the
combustion of fossil fuels.
And obviously, this
is out of date.
We're already over 400 PPM.
I have another video here.
There it is.
So this is what that CO2 has
done in a very nice visual.
We humans have cranked the knob.
They've taken the
CO2 dial and they've
turned it hard to
the right, very hard.
This is a surface
temperature anomaly
map based on instrumental
data from around the world.
Want to see that one again?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
It's cool.
So what you're
looking at is the mean
is defined as 1951 to 1980.
And so what you're looking
at is every surface anomaly
relative to that mean.
So the beginning is generally
lower than the mean.
And as you see, when
you get towards the end,
you're generally
hotter than the mean.
In partnership with that
warming atmosphere, heat
penetrating the ice sheets,
heat penetrating the ocean,
causing thermal
expansion of the oceans
and melting of the ice sheets,
sea level has been rising.
These are various
different studies
based on different techniques,
including tide gauges.
And they're in more disagreement
the further back in time
you go.
But I think what everybody
is in agreement about is
that sea level is rising and
the rate is accelerating.
This is from a post-doc at
Harvard, Carling [INAUDIBLE].
And just to take this
time window, 1900 to 2000,
and put it on a time scale of
the last 2,000 years-- right?
It's all about
perspective, right?
Here's that same curve.
You would put it right here.
So natural variability,
the rise in sea
level due to two
human-induced global warming.
So what is the-- I'll
just wrap up here.
One more slide.
What is the
atmospheric CO2 and sea
level likely to do over
the coming century?
And of course, it's not
just the next 100 years.
It's many hundreds of
years into the future.
This is not a
scientific question
that scientists can answer.
This is a question that's going
to be completely dependent
on the individual and
collective actions of citizens
and their governments.
But I will say that
if you look at this,
here is our current
CO2 emission rates.
And what this is
showing is these
are the paths that, as a planet,
we have to choose to be on.
Can we turn around
global CO2 emission rates
quickly or is it
going to take longer?
And the point to make here
is even if you turned it
around today, you're
still putting CO2
into the atmosphere.
Much of it's going into
the ocean, but most of it
stays in the atmosphere.
And it will stay there
for hundreds of years.
So even if you turned
it around today,
you're committing
yourself to CO2 levels up
around 500 parts per million.
Every decade you put it
off, you commit yourself
to higher and higher sea
levels down the road.
So as someone who knows
what these changes in CO2
have done in the past, this
would be of great concern.
OK.
So I'll just thank
you for listening.
And happy to take
questions later.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, good morning.
I'm Rebecca Woodgate
from the University
of Washington, Seattle.
And for the next
20 minutes, I would
like to take you up to
the top of the world,
peer into the Arctic,
like this polar bear is
appearing into her Arctic.
In her case, she sees a
submarine come at her.
Something she doesn't
understand, probably.
There's things about the Arctic
we do and do not understand.
This word here, Uggianaqtuq--
it's an Inuit word.
It means "a friend
acting strangely."
And that's how the Inuit,
who have lived in the Arctic
now for around 10,000 years,
how they now view the Arctic.
A system that they
know and love,
which is behaving in ways
they cannot understand.
Where is the Arctic?
It falls off a lot of maps.
Here it is at the
top of these maps.
It turns up squashed into
a little layer at the top.
But if you take a globe and you
peer down from the top of it,
you can see there's a
proper ocean up there.
You can twist this map
round because it is usual
when you're talking
about the Arctic
to put the country you're
talking in at the bottom.
Lots of countries here.
Lots of countries vying
for owning the Arctic.
This picture-- anyone
know this picture?
This is the Russians
putting their flag
at the North Pole, three miles
down under the ocean, in 2007,
saying it's theirs.
We're not going
to go there today,
but there's interesting
debates about that.
Give you an idea of scale,
this is relative to something
I hope you recognize.
It's bigger than the US.
If you want some numbers,
here's some numbers on it.
It's the smallest of the
world's five major oceans.
But it's famous in
many, many ways,
even before the changes of
recent days, for frozen ships,
for passageways, for the hunt
for the North Pole, et cetera.
Perhaps of the most poignant
is the Northwest Passage,
which is this route between
the Atlantic Ocean, which
is down here, and the Arctic.
The search for the
Northwest Passage.
And let's start there.
Let's start with some
recent Arctic ships.
Can anyone tell me what this is?
This is the wreck
of the HMS Terror.
This was a ship which set
sail from England in 1850,
1845, looking for the
Northwest Passage.
The Franklin Expedition, the
lost Franklin Expedition.
It's not a happy story.
They overwintered three
years in the archipelago
trying to find a way through.
After more than one and a
half years struck in the ice,
they left the ship trying to
walk South and none of them
survived.
And since then, we've been
looking for those ships.
We found those ships
in the last year.
I say we-- this is Parks Canada.
The Canadians put a lot
of effort into doing this.
This is the ship
on happier days.
Some years before this, 1836,
getting stuck in the sea ice
was an occupational
hazard of being an Arctic
explorer in those days.
So another ship in
the news this summer.
Anyone know this one?
This is the Crystal Serenity,
a luxury cruise liner,
1,000 passengers, 700
crew, which had just
gone through the same fabled
Northwest Passage in three
weeks, stopping
in villages which
have a population
less than a third
of the number of
people on the ship.
Contrast these, the
Franklin's Expedition.
Here they are.
This is as far as they got.
This is where, basically,
the whole crew perished.
Nobody came home.
And the Crystal
Serenity, which has
gone through in a nice
planned trip for three weeks,
come out in New York.
What's the difference?
The difference
between this is ice.
Let's talk about ice.
So if I take sea
water and freeze it,
I start to get very
little crystals.
They float up to the
surface of the ocean.
They form a kind
of an oily layer
on the top of the ocean, which
gradually pushes together
to form a sheet of ice.
OK.
This has some resilience.
I wouldn't walk on
this at this stage,
but it will push together
and you can see the edges.
You can see here the
striations of the layers
push against each other.
Let it go a bit further
and these layers
form into more sheets.
If you're a penguin,
you can walk on this.
No, there are no
penguins in the Arctic.
As these sheets come together,
we call this pancake ice.
People at sea will think
of a lot of things.
And they get thicker and come
together over a period a few
more days to make
into ice floes.
Ice floes can be several yards
to a mile to several miles
across.
I don't know how you got
here, but this gives you
an idea of scale.
This is the first time that
I would walk on this stuff.
This is about one
to two meters thick.
So here to here thick.
This is first year ice,
will form over season.
Here's a ship plowing
through the ice.
As it goes through, it
pushes the ice up on edge
so you can see how thick the
ice is from here to here.
This is not how we get the
thickest ice in the Arctic.
If you just let it grow
over more than one year,
it would grow to three
meters, not quite reach that.
Nine feet tall.
But what makes it really thick
is as those pieces of ice,
those floes of ice push
together, they ridge,
just like a mountain
range will ridge.
And this is what makes our
thickest pieces of ice.
I've put here a picture from
one of the pretty buildings
from my university.
90 feet tall is this tower.
And that is a not atypical
height for a ridge
that you'd get in the Arctic.
Just like an iceberg, there's
more below than above.
So if we have this chap
standing here beside the ice,
and we measure how far
above the water he would be
and how far below
the keel, you're
looking about an ice keel about
the height of that building.
So these are common
sizes of thicknesses
of ice in the Arctic.
Now, while this is
pushing together here,
it's coming apart
somewhere else.
And this gives us
what is called leads
in the ice, cracks in the ice
which can appear overnight.
Very, very quickly.
Sometimes in
inconvenient places.
This is a current hazard
of Arctic exploration,
as you might get a lead
come through your camp
in the middle of the night,
with interesting consequences.
Didn't fall in, we
don't really mind.
I prefer to work off
ships for that reason.
And you can see some ships here.
Here the ship is giving
the scale of the ice floes.
As the summer carries
on, the sun melts,
the snow on the top
of the ice gives you
melt ponds in the top of the
ice, which will eventually
decay the ice away.
It is a habitat
for life, is ice.
We have our
charismatic megafauna.
And we have our, perhaps, not
so charismatic tiny fauna.
This little brown striations
you see here, that's not mud
and that's not
paint off the ship.
That is actually little
microbial community plankton
which are growing in
the channels of ice.
You can do this yourself.
Go home, take some salty
water, chuck it in the freezer.
And tomorrow morning, put
drops of food coloring in it
and you can see
the channels that
go through the sea ice
which are channels for life.
It's also home for people.
The Inuit have
made their history
in the Arctic for 10,000 years.
And to them, ice
is not a hindrance.
Ice is their way
of getting around.
Ice is their highway.
So where are we today?
This is almost
today's sea ice there.
This is a satellite image.
Greenland's here.
The colors give you
the ice concentration.
These dark areas are water.
You can see the sea
ice now building up
from it's expanding as
the winter has started
in the North, expanding
back out to the coasts
and down into the
lower latitudes.
That's a snapshot of today.
It's a large seasonal
cycle in the sea ice.
This again, satellite data.
We're over here,
again, now showing
the maximum extent in winter and
the minimum extent in summer.
Occur March and
September respectively.
Large seasonal
change, of course,
because the sun comes
up and melts the ice.
Well, how does this year
compare with the past?
We have this satellite
data back to 1979.
And I pulled out
the years which have
the maximums in the seasons and
the minimums in the seasons.
And to make it a
bit easier to see,
I'm going to change it
now to sea ice extent.
And this pink line
in both of these maps
shows the monthly median
edge from '81 to 2010.
So what we thought was standard
for most of our satellite
record.
So in the winters, you know,
we're kind of close to that.
Getting a few changes.
But the summers, we're seeing
this very dramatic loss
of sea ice.
Let's put those on time scales.
Here we have the whole
time series we have,
and the trend line through that.
And it's not very much.
It's a few percent per decade.
This is the winter.
But in the summer, we're getting
a very much greater change,
13% per decade.
OK.
That's we're losing--
13% of the ice per decade
we're losing in the Arctic.
To look at where we're
losing it, in the winter,
we're losing it
around the edges.
In the summer, we're
losing it in the middle.
We'll come back to these
patterns in a moment.
So we're losing ice area?
Oh, yeah.
The area that we've lost
so far is about a third
of the area of the US.
And we've probably
lost about 50%
of the old summer sea ice
extent, from about the 1980s.
It's not just that
that we've lost.
We've also thinned the ice.
So it's harder to
put this together.
We put together from submarines
and satellite images.
But this gives you an
idea, in the 1980s--
this is winter and summer-- we
had about three meters of ice.
And now, in more recent era,
we're down to about half that.
This satellite picture's showing
you how that's distributed.
There's lots of statistics
that have to go into this.
But this is confirmed
by everybody
who goes up there, the
people who live there,
who talk about--
saying we no longer get
the strong, thick
ice we used to have.
We only have feeble,
weak, young ice.
So you can say sea ice is thin
from very roughly about 50%.
Put that together, we've
lost extent, we've thinned.
We end up with a loss of volume.
This is our best estimate to
try and put that all together,
which is a model, and which
says we have lost basically 30%.
No, we've not lost 30%,
we only have 30% left
of the summer ice
that used to have.
OK?
Some people will say
this is a quarter,
but it's around that magnitude.
So there's a huge change
we've seen in the Arctic
in the last decades.
How did we get here?
Polar bear.
We're always going
to have a polar bear.
How did he get there either?
So we got there in many ways.
Things that we understand
and things that we don't.
We understand now how
well the ice moves.
So if we put a pole in
the ice at the North Pole,
the floe drifts around
and the ice moves with it.
To be more useful
in that, we can
put in a set of
instruments which
will tell you their position.
So dates rolling
in the corner here.
White is the satellite
sea ice extent
going from the
summer to the winter
to the summer to the winter.
And the little red
dots are buoys that
have been put on the ice
and register their position.
You see they go around in a
kind of circle around here.
Some of them run down the
edge of Greenland like this.
This is how the
sea ice is moving.
They're just sat on the sea ice.
They jiggle around
together because the wind
is forcing them.
And we can see this pattern
of a circulation there,
and then ice coming around here
and coming out down this way.
And as we come to the 2000s,
we see the summer extent
getting less every year.
And we can see this melting
back to this incredible ice
melt in 2007, which really was
something that nobody expected
or saw coming.
So from that data, we can
go on and say, well, we
can see how this is moving.
We can tell how old the ice is.
And this is a similar movie
where the colors are now
the age of the ice.
So white is now
greater than 10 years,
and these bluer colors are more
recent, younger ice than that.
It's the same buoys
as you saw before.
We're seeing here in the
1980s, most of the Arctic
was covered by old ice.
But changes in the
wind have changed that.
We've taken all
this area of ice,
then managed to flush
it out down here
through to the Atlantic Ocean.
And over this time period,
we're losing the older ice
in the Arctic and
coming back to just
having a very much younger,
newer ice in the Arctic Ocean.
We've flushed the
old stuff all away.
To see the before and after, if
you like, here is the before.
Lots of old ice.
And here is the new with
very little ice left.
In doing that,
we've flushed away
the old, thick, resilient ice.
It now moves faster
and it's thinner.
The other thing
that goes with that
is that it can also melt easier.
If we look at how
things have changed,
is it just due to this motion?
No, it's not.
This is a movie of 2000, again
looking at ice and clouds now.
So here's Greenland again.
And you see here the coast of
Alaska around these points.
The big things that
swell past are clouds.
But mostly, what
you see underneath,
this is the ice moving.
Sometimes the wind blows.
You'll see black open up here.
That's open water opening up
along the coast you see here.
You see-- if you
watch this bit, you
can kind of sense
the motion, which is
the same motion we saw before.
You see these
massive cracks coming
across the whole of the Arctic.
Those are the leads
that we talked about
as the ice pulls apart
driven by winds and currents.
In summer here, the ice starts
to pull back from the coast.
And you can see here the retreat
of the edge, which is faster
than the speed of the ice.
Basically, as we watch
those through August
and through September, that
ice just entirely melts away.
OK.
So what causes it to melt?
The main thing is this idea
of an ice albedo feedback.
This is the reflectivity that
was talked about a second ago.
Quite simply, the ice is
shiny and the water is not.
So if sunlight beats on the
ice, it reflects that heat back
to space.
If it beats on open water,
that heat is absorbed
and we get a feedback.
Let's say we start
with more ocean water.
That water can absorb more heat.
That means it will
get warmer, which
means it will melt
some more ice, which
means we have more open
water, which means we
go round and round this circle.
It's a vicious circle.
A vicious circle of
demise of sea ice.
The technical physical term for
that is a positive feedback.
And so once we can set
this off, the only thing
that's going to stop this
is by turning off the light.
Winter coming is the only thing
that will stop this feedback.
But we have to set this off.
And to set this
off, what can we do?
We can blow the
wind off the coast.
But there's a further role
which is bringing heat
into the Arctic, and
that is the oceans.
This is now a map of the
bathymetry of the Arctic Ocean.
Deep bits of blue about the
size of our local volcano
in Seattle.
The shallow red bits
are more shallow.
And there's other
things there that
give you some idea of scales.
We have an entrance here
to the Atlantic Ocean,
an entrance here to the Pacific.
And waters flow from both of
those oceans into the Arctic.
Here's the Atlantic water which
comes in, the deep current.
And it likes to put its
hand on the right hand wall
like a good current should
in the Northern hemisphere,
because the Earth is spinning.
And it goes around
following slopes and ridges.
It goes around very slowly,
a few centimeters per second.
So it'll take eight
hours to go one mile.
So if we send some
water in here,
depending whether it
takes the short route back
through here or the longer
loops back through here,
it can take 10, 20, or 30
years to get back out again.
So we send a heat
signal into the Arctic,
that the time it's going to
go around and then come back.
On the other side, the water
comes from the Pacific.
That's higher up in
the water column.
It's also a lot fresher.
It tends to stay with
the top of the ocean.
And it's more driven by
the ice and by the winds.
It moves a lot faster.
It actually covers about
half of the Arctic Ocean
here, then comes out through
the Canadian archipelago.
So it will only take about
10 years to cross the Arctic.
What both these currents
have in common is
they bring in heat
to the Arctic Ocean.
Here's some pictures
off the Fram Strait,
seeing the heat from the ocean
coming up and melting the ice.
If we look at that
Atlantic layer, [INAUDIBLE]
that we had for that, and
we look at the ice edge,
we can see here these
tongues of hot water coming
across Greenland
and the Bering Sea
here, melting back the ice edge.
Very suggestive
from the patterns
that the oceans are
bringing in the heat, which
is melting off the ice.
And I show you
that as a pattern,
that we can do the maths.
We've had measurements
in these channels
at great expense for many years.
We can see that
over these decades,
the temperature of the
waters have warmed as we
go through the channel there.
And you can do the maths,
so you can work it out.
But we're just about right
for the numbers, the amount
of winter ice that we're
losing in this area, which
is 10% per decade in
this particular area,
is likely caused by an ocean
warming of 0.3% per decade.
It corresponds to
that map we had
of where we saw the ice
going away in winter.
We flip over to the
other side of the Arctic,
the Pacific, here
the water's coming in
and only warm in the summer.
But we see the same pattern.
We have here the same,
the tongues of water,
again driven by the topography,
melt back tongues in the ice.
And this is now.
We've got the sun up here.
We can set this off.
And now the ice albedo feedback
can take over and melt back
the ice.
The other thing that
this water does,
it ends up deeper
in the Arctic Ocean
and it can add to
the gradual thinning
to the ice that is there.
Yet another nail in the coffin
of the poor Arctic sea ice.
Again, we've had measurements
here for many years.
We can see this heat
flow increasing.
And we can do the
maths, and we can say,
this is the effect
of these heat flows.
We've got warmer waters
coming in from both sides.
So what is our causes of
recent sea ice retreat?
The increased heat
from the Pacific,
increased heat
from the Atlantic.
Warmer atmospheres I
haven't talked about,
but that's coming into this too.
Added on to a
preconditioning, where
we have flushed this older
ice out of the Arctic.
So all of these
things are conspiring
to give the Arctic
a really bad day.
Right?
We've all had bad
days like this.
This is the Arctic's bad day.
Quite how these interplays,
things that we still
have to put together.
We have so far not
managed to predict
any of these extreme ice
melt years that we have had.
So what sort of
a hole are we in?
This guy-- this is how we used
to do Arctic oceanography.
This is one of our technicians
who has chiseled his way down
through a bit of sea ice.
OK, this is a good
bit of sea ice.
Chiseling down so he can
get to the ocean below.
OK?
Digging himself a hole.
The ice albedo feedback is kind
of a killer in all of this.
It comes with the idea
of polar amplification.
We saw that in an earlier
video, though you may not
have been looking for it.
The poles are going to warm
first, especially the Arctic,
because we are
losing the albedo.
We're losing the
shininess of the Earth,
and we're allowing
all that energy
to absorb into the ocean.
Quite how that is going to play
out as we push those Arctic
waters into the
rest of the world,
we haven't quite worked out.
That's more Lynne's
field than mine.
What also comes with
this is a change
in the atmospheric circulation.
There is a cap of
cold air which sits
over the Arctic which basically
can get extra wobbles on it.
And those wobbles are thought
to be driven by changes
in the sea ice extent.
And that gives us the
cold air outbreaks
and the dumping of snow onto
the East Coast that we've
seen in recent years.
This is how the Arctic
extends its fingers down
into mid-latitude weather.
There is also the
impact in the Arctic
of where the warming
that we're having,
permafrost thawing, loss of
ice protection from erosion.
If the ice pulls back
earlier, the storms
can affect things more.
And we have whole villages
falling into the sea.
Loss of infrastructure
in terms of roads,
buildings that are
built on permafrost.
Also within the permafrost,
we have a large store
of methane hydrates.
These are frozen
methane under the sea.
Currently stable,
but as we warm,
we could release that with
potentially huge consequences.
We don't quite know how that
one will play out either.
We also have with
this the opportunities
which are coming from this--
exploitation of resources
and Arctic shipping,
which can now talk
about going across the pole.
And in all of this too,
we think about the peoples
and the governments.
There are people
who live up there,
who this is their way of life.
And there are the governments
of the world who are clamoring
to own that piece of the ocean.
So what have we seen in
our trip around the Arctic?
We've changed the seasonal
ice extent, how it changes.
How we've thinned the ice.
If you take just that one
number, take away this.
We're only left
with 30% of the ice
that we used to have in the
summer just a few decades ago.
We've looked at why that
things might be causing that.
And we've looked at the possible
implications of all of this.
It's a field which, because
of the ramifications,
these broad ramifications, and
the way the thing interacts,
we really need not just an
interdisciplinary, but also
a cross-cultural
approach to have
a responsible and coherent
way of going forward
into the future.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
Now for some more good news.
[LAUGHTER]
Here we go.
Well, I live in--
I'm from Scripps.
This is what it
looks like every day.
So up here, I have
to put on a jacket.
I thought I would go ahead and
put my cartoon, my favorite one
out in front,
because we've lived
in kind of a politicized
environment the last two years
as climate scientists.
And I think it's
ameliorating a little bit.
We're going back to some sanity.
But this is one I've had
in there a long time.
And I'm going to
talk a bit about how
we get from oceans
to drought, or what
we can learn about the
water cycle of the planet
from what we measure
in the ocean.
And I actually have a very
brief set of definitions,
because we have-- actually,
speaking from a place of-- I'm
going to show a lot of results
from the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change, IPCC.
I had the great privilege
to be part of it
the last two reports we put
together the first time.
It had an oceans
chapter two times ago.
And we continued
that with this one.
So I'm going to
show a lot of stuff
from a particular slant
in the IPCC of how
the oceans are
changing and how they
contribute to climate change.
But first, you want to know
what we're talking about.
So there's climate.
And there's climate variability.
We have a lot of that.
And there's El Nino.
Some years are stormy, some
years are not, et cetera.
That's natural.
And we have major natural
climate variability
on the planet.
And that can be affected
by climate change, which
is what we drive through
anthropogenic forcing.
And so we're seeing all
kinds of records now.
So I just want to get those
two definitions in place.
It's kind of, well,
[INAUDIBLE] such
that we have a framework there.
These are four major overarching
conclusions from the IPCC.
This is not the oceans part.
This is the whole thing.
Number one, which Susan Solomon
put forward in the 2007 IPCC
as the head of the
working Group 1,
warming of the climate
system is unequivocal.
We came home from that
with buttons to wear.
Warming is unequivocal.
Global warming does
not cause ice ages.
That was the second
part of that.
Number two, human influence
on the climate is clear.
Number three, continued
greenhouse gas emissions
will cause further warming.
And number four,
limiting climate change
requires substantial sustained
reductions of emissions.
So let's look at the Earth.
Is it warming?
We've already seen
this in video.
This is the trend since
1901 up through 2012.
Where it's white is where
there's not enough data.
Mostly it's warming.
There it is.
And it's mostly
warming over land,
but it's warming over the
sea, and that's important.
This is from this wonderful
NASA website, climate.nasa.gov.
Go on there if you want to put
something on your Facebook page
there every day from there.
It's great.
There is our graph.
And when you go online,
actually, that red
dot at the end animates.
Boom, boom, boom.
It's the hottest ever
measured with direct records
this past year.
And this year, 2016, was higher.
So there we are.
We're getting warmer.
And they give you a nice number
for how much warmer we are.
It's almost one degree warmer.
It's projected to get warmer.
And there's-- the IPCC has
different ways of going about
that with business as usual, or
some reductions, or whatever.
So you get from
moderate to extreme.
The one on the left is--
the right, your right,
is obviously more extreme.
But that's where we're going
if you just burn it all.
And you see the
polar amplification
that Maureen and Rebecca were
talking about due to the ice
changes in the North.
And you see the ocean in the
South is not doing a lot.
There's a lot of
ocean down there.
Water has a lot
of heat capacity.
What's creating climate change?
Greenhouse gases mainly.
This is the big
elephant in the room.
And they are the dominant
cause of observed warming.
There's other ways--
very complicated subject,
but this is the big part of it.
And the largest
contribution is CO2.
And this is the Keeling
curve last night, 401.
We're actually at
the low for the year
because we're at the end of
the northern hemisphere summer.
This is measured at
the top of Mauna Loa.
Dave Keeling set this
up in the International
Geophysical Year, 1957.
And with dogged
persistence, kept it going.
And now it's recognized as
our really amazing record.
You see the planet
breathing, and the summertime
and wintertime,
summertime and wintertime.
And relentlessly going up.
And that's the tail at
the end of the curve
that Maureen showed.
What happens with
the greenhouse gases?
We get lots of stuff
happening, bad stuff.
Well, different stuff.
It depends on whether
it's good or bad.
Warming-- atmosphere and ocean.
We melt the ice.
We melt the ice sheets.
We raise sea level.
We do change the
hydrological cycle.
We're going to change the
patterns of drought and floods.
Not the patterns, but the
strength of drought and floods.
We have more extreme events.
You can't attribute any given
storm to global warming,
but you can attribute years
of changes in extreme events.
Ocean acidification is another
important one for the ocean.
So looking at the ocean,
how does the ocean
participate in each
of these parts of it?
In carbon-- just
one or two slides--
heat, and ice, just a
little bit, sea level rise,
and the water cycle.
So a statement from
the IPCC-- the ocean
has absorbed about 30% of the
emitted anthropogenic carbon
dioxide.
OK, that's an important number.
You put a certain amount of
carbon up in the-- you burn it.
It's coming from fossil--
it's fossil fuel burning.
8% land, 92%
percent fossil fuel.
Fossil fuel burning
into the atmosphere.
A third stays up there, a third
goes into fertilizing the land,
and a third goes into the ocean.
And the ocean is not going
to sit there and soak up
the next 40%, 50%, 60%.
This is an equilibrated
sort of system.
And once it's there, it's there.
Maureen showed a nice
graph showing that we're
in a commitment phase.
You put the CO2
in the atmosphere.
It's not going anywhere.
A third goes into the ocean
of the part that goes up.
How do you get it out?
Well, you have to stop
burning it to keep it flat.
And then maybe you need
to start removing it.
Here's the other CO2 problem.
The ocean is 70% of
the Earth's surface.
That CO2, 30% that
goes into the ocean,
it's not a garbage dump that
you just put in the backyard.
It goes in and it
affects the marine life.
So you get acidification.
Carbonic acid is formed when
you dissolve CO2 into water.
A little bit changes the pH.
And that excess acid has
important impacts on organisms.
And there's a pteropod.
They're kind of in danger.
They have beautiful
movies of them--
I didn't bring any
animations-- flittering around.
The poor pteropods.
Anyway, coral reefs,
et cetera, you
may read about all these things.
And this is going on now.
And so there are projections
of how the surface
pH will change in
the ocean, and also
how the undersaturation,
how much acidification
is impacting the organisms.
That's it for carbon.
That's an important second
part of the carbon problem,
if you haven't been kind of
cued into it before though,
that the oceans are affected
by the extra carbon as well.
Now we go to heat.
OK.
So you've heard
this number already,
that the excess energy in the
system due to anthropogenic
forcing.
So this is the excess.
Not just the heat, but the
excess is more than 90%
of what's in there.
So yay, the ocean is
really helping us out.
If that were in the atmosphere,
think of how warm we would be.
And I'll show a graph.
How do we know these things?
So this is where we
get to what I do.
We go out to sea and
make measurements.
How do we know
where the heat is?
We measure it.
This is the latest--
yesterday's, maybe today,
yesterday-- map of where we
have had ocean temperature
and salinity profiles
over the last month.
So we have a global network now.
It's been a
phenomenal community,
international effort.
Technology was invented
at Scripps by Russ Davis.
Dean Roemmich at
Scripps has been
instrumental in taking
this to the world.
Taking the instruments
to the world.
This is our network
for the ocean.
It's the upper 2,000
meters of the ocean.
That is a picture
of a float that we
were putting out off of a ship
in the Indian Ocean last year.
Here's what you get from it.
Is the ocean
temperature changing?
Yeah, it is.
This is the change
in heat content
in the upper part of the
ocean-- 700 meters times three,
2,000 feet-- since 1950.
Mostly red.
Oh, OK.
And then there's a lot of really
interesting structure to it
that we could spend days
and months discussing.
But it's mostly red.
It's pretty patchy,
because we're
using measurements since 1950.
So it's ship measurements
in addition to these floats.
And then-- I'm in the middle
of that one-- we go out to sea
and we measure to get the rest
of the ocean to the bottom,
to see how it's changing
over the decades.
And we make extremely
accurate measurements.
And here's a map from Sarah
Purkey and Greg Johnson.
How to make your thesis
become a classic--
you get 10,000 citations.
This is the map.
This is using our very precise--
very accurate-- not precise
but very accurate
deep measurements
to look at where the warming is
happening below 4,000 meters.
And you see it's a
very different pattern.
This is a big eye opener.
It's very much in the South.
And this is where a deep
water forms around Antarctica
and goes to the bottom.
And the balance is changing.
And essentially, the deep water
is changing in properties.
There's less of it.
And that makes the
deep ocean warm.
So we have a lot of
interesting observations,
a lot of interesting
things to think about.
This is our take home
graph on warming.
There's the title, "Global
warming is ocean warming."
And there is our-- let's
see, is there a pointer here?
Yes, there's a pointer.
I'm going to show this.
Here we go.
OK, this is the total heat in
the whole system, everything.
So this is not
just anthropogenic.
This is it.
There's some funny units
over here, zettajoules.
This is years since we've had
enough measurements to do this.
There's the total.
OK, down here, there's a
little tiny purple line.
That's the atmosphere.
That's how much the
atmosphere is warm.
So there was huge press
[INAUDIBLE] about the hiatus.
Anybody heard of the
hiatus out there?
There's a lot of skepticism.
Well, the skeptics could say,
oh, the climate's not changing,
because look, it's flat
for the last 10 years.
Well, that was flat in
this curve down here.
Is it flat in that one?
Oh, no.
What is this?
This is the upper ocean, the
upper 700 meters of the ocean.
This is the deep ocean,
below 700 meters.
You see, this is the
93% we're talking about.
There's bumps and wiggles.
Yes, there's
climate variability,
but there's a relentless
upward swing there.
And most of the heat is in
the ocean, thank goodness.
But it also means
that's what's happening.
When we have these bumps
and wiggles in our surface
temperature, hiatus, et
cetera, what's happening
is there's an exchange between
the ocean and the atmosphere.
And the ocean is sitting
there going, yeah OK,
let's have a mode.
And let's take up some heat
and change the temperature
at the surface.
But the heat in the
whole system is going up.
What's this doing?
Overall, the heating
of the whole system.
There's the ice.
The Greenland and Antarctic
ice sheets are losing mass.
Glaciers are continuing
to shrink worldwide.
That's not the ocean
so I'm not showing it.
Arctic sea ice, et cetera.
And the Antarctic sea
ice has expanded, which
is very interesting topic.
And there's workshops
going on about that.
That's attributable
to-- the largest
extent is in the winter when
there's no ice albedo feedback.
It's dark down there.
And the wind is blowing stronger
because of global warming.
And the wind pushes the ice out.
So the cover is going up.
We've already seen these great
pictures of the Arctic ice.
Here's the ice sheet warming.
This is Greenland, where
it's warming and losing mass.
There's the mass loss.
This is Antarctica
where it's warming.
Here's the mass loss.
You note it's not
the whole thing.
So yeah, we're going to be
kind of happy with only--
how many meters was that?
- Six.
- Six meters, as opposed to 180.
Six meters of ice loss.
As an oceanographer,
we're interested in this.
You've already seen from
Rebecca and from Maureen
how the ocean affects
the ice balance.
This is in the Antarctic.
This is the Antarctic ice sheet.
This is the increased ice loss
from the Antarctic ice shelves.
And the ocean is a
part of the culprit.
It's not just the
atmospheric temperature,
but the ocean is wrapping
warm water coming out
of the North Atlantic.
It's spiraling upwards
towards Antarctica.
Guess where it hits
x marks the spot?
Over here.
So this is where it spirals
in very close to Antarctica.
And we're working
hard on quantifying
that in models, how
much of this ice loss
is due to accelerations of
this pathway of warm water
to the surface.
So you don't see the
third dimension here.
It's going from 3,000 meters
deep up to 200 meters.
This is the mean state.
This is the way the
ocean is set up.
So this is the
incursion of warm water.
And changes in that,
probably due to winds,
may increase this
mass loss over here.
Are the seas rising?
Yes, you've already
seen that they are.
Here's the IPCC summary.
Rate of sea level rise has
been larger than the mean rate
during the previous
two millennia.
It's gone up 20 centimeters.
Well, 20 centimeters,
oh, that's not very much.
You go oh, go home, sleep well.
Who cares?
Oh, well, with that
20 centimeters also
comes an increase in the-- and
the more storminess-- storm
surges go up.
There's a change--
there's actually
different rates for
different parts of the tide.
That aside, well, let's say--
well, the most important thing
about that 20 centimeters
is that it's relentless.
So I'll show you
a graph and to--
First, I want to just
give you a little pedagogy
here on why sea level goes up.
It goes up for three reasons.
Number one, the ocean
warms so it expands.
OK, that's all that heat there.
Number two, ice sheets,
land-based ice melt.
Not sea ice.
Sea ice is like ice
cubes in your iced tea.
When it melts, your iced
tea doesn't overflow.
But when the ice sheet
melts, it does fill up.
So you're adding water to the
ocean from glaciers and ice
sheets.
So the sea ice melt
doesn't change it,
but the ice sheet
melt, the shelf melting
and ice sheet melting does.
Those are two big factors.
The third big factor in
the change in sea level
is rebound over
thousands of years.
You can go on this
wonderful NOAA website
and find information
from all the long tide
gauges around the coastlines.
And you'd see a pattern,
mostly up arrows.
And these are from
the tide gauges,
some of our favorite ones.
The down ones may
be the rebound.
OK, La Jolla.
We just celebrated 100
years of La Jolla records.
It's out at the end
of the pier there.
People are out there
every single day
making manual measurements
of temperature and salinity.
There is an automated
tide gauge out there.
100 years-- is 100
years enough was
the question that was posed.
Well, yeah.
Should we stop?
No.
Don't stop, because
here's the record.
You fit a line through it.
Relentlessly going up.
Lots of bumps and wiggles.
And if you only have 20 years,
or you stop, what do you know?
You've got to keep measuring it.
So this tide gauge goes.
And let's move over to Boston.
What's going on here?
Ooh, same answer.
1921, out there in
the Boston Harbor,
in this kind of very
picturesque corner,
is the Boston tide gauge
that's been there since 1921,
maintained by the Coast Guard.
And the same kind of picture,
bumps and wiggles, and a line
fit through it going
up relentlessly.
You can make a map.
This map doesn't look like
it's going up relentlessly.
There's places where it's
blue, it's going down.
This is only since 1993.
If you went back to these
things and started in 1993,
you might see sea
level going down.
So you're seeing natural modes
of variability superimposed
on relentless sea level rise.
So the idea is that
it keeps going up.
Here's the projections.
It should be up by
at least a meter
by the end of the century.
OK.
So last but not least, that sea
level is just going to come up.
What about our rain?
What about our drought?
What about the things that
matter to agriculture?
What about the
things that matter
to populations in arid areas?
OK.
So what we're going
to be able to see here
is that the ocean salinity
is acting as a global rain
gauge, which is great.
We can actually learn a
lot from ocean measurements
that we can't from just
rain gauges on land.
What we've found, to summarize
and then go through why,
is that since the
'50s, where the surface
waters are saltiest,
they've gotten saltier.
Where they're fresher,
they've gotten fresher.
That means we've changed
the amount of evaporation
and precipitation.
It's doing more of both.
So places that are evaporating
are evaporating more.
Places that are raining
are raining more.
And that means that if you
extrapolate that over to land,
where you have arid regions,
they become more arid.
Where you have wet regions,
they become wetter.
So we have seen over
the ocean enhancement
of the pattern of evaporation
minus precipitation.
This is some graphs
from land which
are showing this pattern,
that will show it
big time with the ocean, that
the dry areas are getting
drier, the wet areas
are getting wetter.
This is rich get richer, poor
get poorer in terms of water.
They can only measure
that over the land.
What we do with the ocean,
these are the mean state
of the ocean.
The top plot is the
surface salinity.
Maybe something you've never
looked or thought about before.
Where it's orange, it's high.
Where it's blue, it's low.
You can see the patterns.
And this bottom plot
is showing evaporation
minus precipitation.
Where it's red is where
there's more evaporation.
Where it's blue is
where there's more rain.
And that matches up pretty
well with the surface salinity
pattern.
So they're very closely
related to each other.
So the way you
change salinity is
you add water or
you subtract water,
because the salt is out there.
It's the dilution.
You put in more water,
it will get fresher.
You take out the
water, it gets saltier.
So we can stack some plots.
That plot of the evaporation
precipitation is here.
This is a world
map in the middle.
This is a world map of the
salinity at the sea surface.
And above them-- well, I'll
do the once on top first.
The one at the top is showing
you the trend in the water
vapor in the atmosphere.
OK, the whole thing that drives
all this is the atmosphere
is warmer, so it can get wetter.
So it's holding more moisture.
So it's cranking more
through, because it
doesn't hold a lot of water.
Most of the water
is in the ocean.
That means it's just picking it
up and dumping it out, picking
it up and dumping it out.
So the trend in water vapor
globally is to be more.
There are some places
that are drier.
Mostly it's wetter.
This map that's noisy, because
our data is kind of noisy,
is the trend in
surface salinity.
And it maps pretty nicely
onto the actual map
of surface salinity.
So that's when we're saying
that the salty areas are
getting saltier, the fresh
areas are getting fresher.
In this sort of noi-- we
have uncertainty measurements
on that, this noisy sense.
So surface salinity is
suggesting that globally we're
having this change
in the pattern.
And then we can
make projections up
to the end of the century using
all these climate models, which
show this pattern of change
in evaporation precipitation.
So the trends look a lot
like the actual situation.
The actual mean state.
So where it is evaporative,
it becomes more evaporative.
So you get dry.
And where it's wet,
you get more floods.
OK.
So I am behind.
I'm going to skip that, just
to summarize and finalize.
Climate change in the ocean.
Earth is warming now.
93% of the heat has
gone into the ocean.
Hydrological balance
is shifting now.
It's strengthening now.
Oceans are acidifying now.
Ice sheets are breaking up and
sea level rise is going on.
All of these are
projected to strengthen.
So there is strong evidence
for climate change.
And I think that's all.
I'll stop there.
[APPLAUSE]
- I would like to
thank the speakers.
And I'll start off with a
few questions to the panel.
And in the meantime,
we'll have a mic set up,
so if you want to ask
questions, we'll go until 12:15.
So let me start off by asking,
maybe Lynne and Rebecca,
there's big differences
between the two poles
and how they work in making
the Earth's climate what it is.
And well, one big difference
is the Arctic is in the ocean
and Antarctica is a land mass.
But there is a circulation
around Antarctica.
Maybe you could throw
some light for us
as to why the Antarctic
ice sheet is not
melting at the rate
that sea ice is melting.
And during the glacial
interglacial fluctuations,
there was a huge
change in ice volume
in the Northern hemisphere.
I believe not as much in
the Southern hemisphere.
So what are the big
differences there?
- I think you already said it.
It's inside out.
So one is ocean
surrounded by land
and the other is land
surrounded by ocean.
And that just completely
changes the way
they respond to the winds.
Both of them have wind patterns.
The Antarctic sea ice area is
out in the westerly wind bands.
That's like where you live
right here up through Greenland.
Whereas the Arctic is
the other direction.
There's a lot of pieces of this.
I don't know where to start.
So there's a lot of ocean
in the Southern hemisphere.
There's a lot of land in
the Northern hemisphere.
That makes it a
different response.
There are easterly winds
ringing around the Arctic.
And the easterly winds
in the Antarctica
are right along the coast.
And they're really important for
pushing water into the coast.
But the main wind
pushes the ice out
from Antarctica
towards where it melts.
So you have this-- what we're
doing with global warming is
spinning up those winds.
They're getting stronger because
the contrast in temperature
are bigger.
There's bigger winds, and
that's pushing ice out farther.
So even if the volume and so
forth is a little different,
the extent is getting bigger.
There's more-- I think that's
the biggest one on the sea ice.
And the Arctic is just warming.
The Antarctic is only warming
in the west Antarctic area.
- Yes, I'd agree
with that, basically.
I mean, you've got just a
very different geography,
which allows different
things to happen.
So around Antarctica, we
have the strongest current
in the world, the
Antarctic circumpolar
current, which manages
to isolate things down
into Antarctica.
In the Arctic, we
don't have that.
We have an ocean we can flow
waters into from either side.
The ice in the Arctic is
generally-- it's sea ice.
It's thin ice.
It's some meters thick.
And the Antarctic's a dirty,
great big chunk of land ice
which is kilometers thick.
So you have a
different whole climate
associated with those things.
It's nice to have
two poles, right?
- During the glacial, was
the Antarctic ice sheet
much thicker?
- So in North America, the
ice that was over Boston
was flowing from central
Canada down to here.
In Antarctica, the ice
expanded, but it was only
able to expand out to the end
of the Arctic ice shelf, which
was more exposed because of
the sea level drop because
of the Northern
hemisphere ice sheet.
But then it just falls off
the continent and flows away.
So it really is--
there's no land for it
to move northward onto.
It's limited by the size
of the Antarctic continent.
- So I have another
question about what
oceanographers call the
meridional overturning
circulation.
So the oceans transport heat
from the tropics to the poles.
And there's been a
lot of papers that
came out about the strength of
this overturning circulation.
From the paleo literature,
we know that in the past,
the strength of the
circulation has changed.
And so what is our
current thinking?
If we melt sea ice and we put
all this fresh water up there
at the poles, do we
think that's going
to change the rate of
deep water formation
and the overturning rate?
Do we have any clues
from the past that--
- Well, you could probably
better speak to the future.
- I could speculate.
- It's certainly
happened in the past.
- That it shutdown?
- Yeah, major reorganization
of ocean currents.
- So maybe you can
tell us what you
think is happening, or
might happen in the future.
And then Maureen can tell us--
- And then somebody
else out there
can come up with a
very different answer.
This is pure
speculation in a sense.
Three sides there.
What really regulates-- OK,
what we're talking about here
is the overturning circulation.
You saw that warm water
on Rebecca's slides going
all the way up into the Arctic.
That is part of the
overturning circulation.
That water is going
all the way up there,
and it's getting cold and
sinking, and coming out.
So that's the North Atlantic
part of the overturn.
That progression of
warm water up there
is important in
keeping passages open.
It's part of the Western
European warming.
That part-- OK, that's one part.
And the Southern Ocean
is the other cold part
of the world, is isolated
by the circumpolar current.
And we have a lot
of ice formation
right around Antarctica.
It makes very dense water
that goes to the bottom.
So we have these two sources.
We have one northern
hemisphere, high latitude source
that does not make deep water,
which is the Pacific Ocean.
And it's our current experiment
in how salt, or lack of salt,
shuts down overturn.
So the contrast between the
Pacific and the Atlantic
is the Pacific has a lot
of rain and is very fresh,
and the Atlantic has a lot
of evaporation so it's salty.
So you put these two things
at both ends of your table
and you say, which one wins if
you cool them both to freezing?
Oh, the salty water will get
dense and the fresh water
will just float on
that salty dense water.
So that's the simple
picture set up
by [? Stommel ?] and
earlier, a long time ago,
we have these two ends.
And that balance
only changes overall
when you move the continents.
That's tectonics.
So then the question is,
what's the vigor of those two
overturns?
The Pacific one is
weak, it's shallow.
The Atlantic one is
10 times stronger
and goes to the ocean bottom.
The question is if you
add a lot of fresh water
from all this melting ice on
top of the North Atlantic,
does it shut that
circulation down, and then
change the amount of
warm water moving north?
And so we had hints that
all this fresh water
was starting to weaken
things a decade or two ago.
The Northern North Atlantic
was relentlessly freshening.
But it turned around.
And some of us went, ha ha.
The circulation
finally caught up.
All that extra evaporation
down off of here,
off of the Gulf Stream
over to Europe and Africa,
the extra evaporation
makes salty water
that got pulled north and
helped keep that cranking.
So my speculation is that,
yeah, the whole thing warms up.
It becomes more stratified.
You're dumping more
fresh water in the north,
but you're also pushing
all this salty water in.
So you've got to have a balance.
And I don't know
which way the balance
will go in the next 100 years.
You need to run a lot
of models to do that.
Maybe some of you have
done that already.
- OK, thank you.
I'm going to pass
it to the audience,
because we have
quite some questions.
So please say your name
and introduce yourself.
- My name's John Wigglesworth
and I'm a secondary school
Earth science teacher.
And I spent a semester teaching
about oceans and climate.
And I wondered if
you had any thoughts
on how to give your
message in a way that
gives young kids some hope.
[LAUGHTER]
It's something that I deal
with all the time working
with eighth graders and
juniors in high school.
And it's a pretty
sobering message.
And how do you do it that
gives people a sense of hope?
- I'm happy to try
to answer that.
So I'm actually
extremely optimistic,
even though it's a very
pessimistic message,
just because I firmly believe
that the limits of-- there
is no limit to human creativity
and our ability to engineer
our way out of this.
But it has to start
with the acknowledgement
of the problem and an effort
to reduce CO2 emissions.
So I'm not sure,
but I think people
have to be empowered by
knowledge of the problem
and want to solve it.
- So I would add to that--
I struggle with this too.
I teach a class on the Arctic.
And you come to the end,
you think, how can I
end on some positive note?
And I think it's to remember
in that that we do have
the ability to change this.
Right?
If we go out there
and see, we're
going to throw all
the money that we're
putting into making ourselves
rich into solving this problem,
we can do it.
Perhaps the most positive thing
I saw in this was somebody
said, right, I know
seven technologies that
could chip away at a
seventh of this problem,
of the CO2 problem.
But we have to teach the
people that this is happening,
that we have to face up to it,
like we teach people to face up
to problems in life.
And go in and do it,
and find on the way
some way of predicting
and mitigating it.
So it's their future.
And I hope we can get them
to grasp it and do something
about it.
And not just blame
it all on our watch.
- And I think
something we can add
is that there have been other
problems for which there was
no political will in
the past, but when
public opinion changed,
political will came about.
So I think there's
hope for that too.
- So take the CFC ban.
We managed to ban CFCs, because
that was a science problem.
So we can do it.
We just have to team
together and actually do it.
- OK.
So the next question.
We're going to have to be
a little quick because we
have five minutes.
- I'm Christina Hernandez.
I'm a graduate student
in the MIT/WHOI Joint
Program in Oceanography.
And I had a question for Rebecca
about sort of ice edge blooms
and the effect of melt
ponds on under ice blooms.
And so I was wondering
if ocean color changes,
whether those blooms happen
under the ice during melt ponds
or at the edges,
if that contributes
at all to these positive
feedbacks that melt the ice.
Like do you know anything
about [INAUDIBLE]?
- So this is really cool.
So the idea is if you're
going to have a phytoplankton
bloom in the ocean, you need to
have nutrients, stratification,
and light.
If we get melt
ponds in the ice, we
get windows in the ocean
which are allowing light
to come into under the ice
regions, which we always
thought were devoid of life
until the ice had melted.
We're finding there are
those blooms in some places.
Quite why, we don't know.
We think because
of the melt ponds,
have they always been there?
We don't know.
What is the feedback then
from that phytoplankton
trapping more energy
into the ocean?
Some-- don't quite know.
We're kind of working on that.
Amala and I are working
on that at the minute.
So we can talk off line.
That's really exciting.
- My name is Tim Johnson
and I'm a software engineer.
And I have one, I
guess, a futuristic kind
of question, in that it
sounds like we're heading
for sort of an alien world.
We don't have to travel
to another planet
to find an alien world.
We're going to get
one right here.
I met that somebody
was from Kuwait,
and he said it's 140
degrees Fahrenheit there
and it's getting hotter.
And to me, that
seems pretty alien.
And it seems to me
that we almost can't
stop what you're describing.
Even if we became much
more politically active
and the Republicans suddenly
became totally different,
we're still not going
to change very fast.
Even if they changed it
tomorrow, passing legislation,
changing things.
And so it seems to me we
have almost a whole new area
of science of how to
deal with the fact
when the world is going to
change over the next century,
because it really is.
Is this sort of something
people are thinking about,
like most businesses are
looking how to make money?
Like you can have
tours taking you
through the Northwest Passage
which didn't exist before.
But it seems like a
sort of a big area.
I suppose it's a way to make
a lot of money for some.
That may encourage some
Republicans to do it.
- There is a big burgeoning
of renewable energy.
And you can see it
around the world.
And Europe is just
going bonk-- it's great.
It's the future.
And the US is going that
direction too, slowly.
There's a whole area of
adaptation and engineering
that is very active.
So encourage your students
to go and work in that.
But don't eliminate
the basic science,
as the Australian government
did for a brief period
the last year.
They said oh, we
know the answer.
Climate is changing.
We don't need you guys anymore.
Let's put all our money
into making some money
on adaptation and engineering.
And there was a big kerfuffle,
because when you have cancer
you don't stop taking
your temperature
because you know
you have cancer.
So we have to have
both legs of that.
We don't represent
that end here,
but maybe some other
people can speak to that.
It's very active.
There are some
geoengineering ideas out
there-- scrubbing the
atmosphere, clean up your mess.
- So if I could
just add to that.
Portugal, I think, ran
entirely on renewable energy
for a period of time
this last summer.
OK?
So it can be done.
We just have to decide
we don't just want money,
we want a world for our
children, as they say.
- OK, thank you very much.
Thank you all for being here.
And of course, John.
- Thanks to the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'd also like to take the
opportunity to thank Amala.
She helped consult as we
were developing this program,
and was extremely
helpful to shape it.
So you deserve a lot
of credit for this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]